nothing not gonna write hello not that
I'm right thank you
yes how are you there your lattes I'm
Cece I'm the ones been talking with
Maddie how are you thank you thank you
baby I love all you thank you and thank
you thank you so much Mario real
pleasure thank you and then add a snake
snakes I don't like snakes I don't like
them thank you my god thank you so much
my god thank you everybody was so
excited thanks cook is there genuine
thank you thank you so much yeah super
excited to be here
let me thank you so much thank you thank
you thank you a lot of guys sure with
our audience I can't wait I really can't
be like that
Maddie asked if it was quarter life
we're gonna do free reporters I've
awesome yeah that all the bad words fly
I seen you and you got it go hi I did
[ __ ] when I do TV in live I never I
never did the audience without my guy
scientists have decided a mind
controlling parasite found in a cat
space that may give people the courage
they need to become entrepreneurs I had
no idea that my life would come down to
me competing with a mind controlling
parasite found in the face of a [ __ ]
cat it's me versus the mind controlling
parasites my guy how are you mister man
so glad we're doing this thank you for
your to be epic order you're in it's
real I promise we will not [ __ ] um
[ __ ] I'm not scared of anything no
no no I'm ready
your your your value here so no thing
[ __ ] I feel you brother kill that Mike
thank you sorry we're going where we're
under construction so you know I come
from the dirt this is fancy I love that
I love that nope nope what's that yeah
it's funny I think I think I that's such
a good point I rock like I think exposed
as the best word right you've been
exposed it's so funny I you know what I
do that a lot actually I realized I've
had to start hedging a little bit in
some quotes where I'm like I don't know
like or I use a negative word as a
positive I do that a lot damage I use
damage we're gonna do a ton of damage
here and it was like oath or god forbid
I use this a good thing
god forbid we [ __ ] get a hit song and
everyone's okay I do that a ton and it's
actually probably a very interesting
insight to doctors a good time to creat
some clarity you know I said if you
drink $6 coffee you're soft if you ever
bought a $5 Starbucks coffee
you're [ __ ] soft if you ever in your
life bought a $5 [ __ ] coffee from
Starbucks
you are [ __ ] soft globally in the
seven point seven billion people your
[ __ ] fancy you're soft
five dollars [ __ ] cup of coffee [ __ ]
you I'm drinking the seven dollar coffee
cuz it's time if you're complaining like
oh I don't have any money or I can't
start my business but you're buying a
six dollar coffee you're soft if you're
not complaining whether you're forty
thousand bucks or forty million bucks
and then drink eight dollar coffee I
don't give up this whole [ __ ] this
whole [ __ ] system is predicated on
complaining you happy don't listen to me
right but the there's so many people I
know that make forty thousand a year and
love life and so many people I know that
have forty million in the bank and hate
life and and and everybody's saying like
cool I'll take my chances I'll be forty
million
I get it but guess what that's what the
forty million person saying to like damn
I wish I didn't wasn't born into this
trust fund people aren't listening and
so eventually we're gonna start
analyzing mental happiness and
everything is gonna start changing and
the reason I talk about materialistic
things
it is the band-aid and the makeup of
unhappiness for ninety five percent the
other five percent just genuinely have
the money and love in like love
camoflage and love that designer and
just like they're very artistic person
cool but man stuff stuff yeah is makeup
and band-aids for unhappiness my guy
thank you so much for having me my god
yes my guy send my guy yes sir here my
guy my guy and you're my guy so just
good I'm flattered I'm flattered the
biggest part is the mindset that it
takes to do that absolutely right
because you know like the biggest thing
I'm worried about is all these people
that are starting businesses that are
gonna fail and then are gonna be sad and
make pretend they didn't fail because
they don't want the judgment
[Music]
with their friends and relatives these
are you concerned and I get it in your
judgment you know to mean [ __ ] judgment
you know cuz you could recover failing
is I love losing I love the I love the
humbleness well there's a lesson in it
I'll give you a good one just happened
that same piece of content with that
woman I was like yo this could have been
bigger
let's repackage it I'm talking to [ __ ]
deep 2d rock I'm like yo this is how
we're gonna package it we put it out
yesterday it did worse and I texted him
and I was like this is the best I love
for all that I think that I get it
better than anybody punched in the mouth
I love it that's good of course not yeah
man I don't get ahead of myself
you know I'm focused on the things that
I gotta do to get there by then I'm
thinking you know when I get it then
I'll start worrying about that I think
that's the greatest era to be alive in
because listen I know what's going on in
society I know about all this but here's
the punchline this internet thing is no
joke no joke
no no and and you preach then like
you're being thoughtful but like making
an arrow to music like look at all the
biggest artists in the world where they
come from SoundCloud Spotify a video
like it's different now it's different
now and you can be in the basement with
a laptop making crazy beats right you
can record your song you don't need the
studio time the same way it's just so
different and so like all these kids
that are if you're not making it now
[Music]
[Laughter]
right well you had to get lucky
quote-unquote cuz you were playing a
show and subkey I think those ANR people
those record executives those companies
they don't have the leverage no more I
don't think you understand if you reach
maybe more people than you think you do
you reach me but following you for a
couple years
thank you my friend and in 2017 you did
your 2017 challenge yes we just sort of
think a little bit more is it you know
what I'm gonna do it I did it and I was
accessible
the 2018 I did it again and I'm four
times as successful this is on the side
it's crazy it's bring those things just
gotta let just got
you start flipping first I do I do well
I didn't green investment for years so I
said you know what let me try some
things that I just don't know about
fraid to do yeah like really secured
ulti covered calls all the other
investment just things that I know that
I've been doing for a long time just had
to trust myself to do it
and I think of myself good I'm doing it
for five years before good New Year's
you're so young you started now thank
you my pleasure take care of guys sorry
well take care thank you okay real quick
yo what up it's Gary B and I'm hanging
with j-cruise la's hip hop morning show
love it thank you my gosh take care
I'm sick hold on Tyler hold on just a
little motivational for my followers
sure yo what up everybody it's Gary Vee
we're just hanging here listen one life
do something about it and stop having
entitlement nobody owes you [ __ ] go get
yours right thanks you're welcome take
care bye bye
yes Barney that is what I'm saying
brands when they think about big media
just care about scale right they're just
like we just need to reach they don't
give a [ __ ] about context then all of a
sudden when it gets to an influencer
like ah she's off-brand like you're so
you spend 40 million on dog [ __ ] for
reach and then you're over scrutinizing
$2,000 cuz she's off-brand are you
[ __ ] kidding me it's crazy it listen
and I'm gonna say this respectfully and
there's a ton of smart people here at
the macro it's a bizarro world in
corporate America and marketing in 2018
[Music]